welcome to blue collar coder and this
week we are going to take a look at
solid js it's a new framework that
competes directly with react it's pretty
exciting stuff but if you're like oh
man
just we need another javascript
framework
i'm going to argue that you're wrong
it's been about five years since spell
which to my mind was the last major
framework so we're pretty much due for
something new so i want to start off
with a viewer comment i've never seen an
expletive framework need so many
additional libraries to solve something
as basic as state joe tile recoil redux
and the list goes on and on this aisle
points to a serious design flaw in the
underlying react technology and you know
what
i agree
so react is being asked to do things
that it was never designed to do
and like any good engineers we always
have to be asking ourselves knowing what
we know today
can we be doing it better
and solid.js is basically a reboot of
react that addresses two primary issues
the first is the vdom and the fact that
these components re-render continuously
it's a performance issue and i'll tell
you what solid.js is blazingly fast and
the second is state management solid.js
has all of the reactive state management
built into it that we see today in hooks
but done better as if
we started from scratch knowing what we
know today so let's take a look at how
we are going to dig into this
so we are going to re-implement this
application this is a simple e-commerce
application it's implemented in react
currently and we're just going to port
it over to solid so let's take a look at
it first i can go and filter stuff down
i can go and click into it i can add it
to cart
i can add it to cart from the home page
we can see the cart over here and i can
clear the cart but i can also refresh
the page and i notice that the cart
still remains because it's stored in
local storage so we're going to do all
of that
in
solid js now we're going to our starting
point is this repository over here it's
got the react version
it's got the finished version so you can
start with that if you want but you can
also start with the starter kit which is
what we're going to do
and that starter kit
is based on solid
and
i use the
typescript starter here so i used this
part first and then i installed tailwind
on top of that
and then i installed
solid js app router on top of that
because this original page has routes on
it and we use react router dom on this
react page so let's head on over to the
terminal and dig right into it
i'm in that directory now and i'm going
to copy recursively the starter into a
new folder called solid ecommerce
and then i'm going to bring that up in
vs code
and from there i'm going to do yarn
and then yarn start
and that's how quickly that comes up
honestly this is vite and it is
incredibly fast so i'll option click on
that
and there's our starter page it's got
tailwind it's got typescript it's
basically got all of the tools we're
going to need
so
let's go take a look over at our react
code and how that's structured just to
get kind of a familiarity with it so it
uses no state manager it just uses all
of the basic react hooks use effect use
state use callback
the first thing it does is bring in a
custom hook called use local storage
it's basically just use state but on
local storage that manages the cart this
is the app component so it's basically
the top of the tree
it then creates some callbacks for
adding to cart clearing the cart
then there's a use effect which goes on
startup so that's because it has an
empty dependency array that hits this
fake api store products page basically
just a nice little fake store api
and then here's some logic for managing
the search bar in that when you are
on a detail page like this if you start
typing
then we're going to see that there's a
change to that search field and then
route you back to the home page so we
can display that that's handled by this
system here with this use callback it's
got this nice dependency array in there
and then finally we've got our basic
structure with the header
the switches for the router for the home
page and then for the product details so
pretty
simple stuff if you're familiar with
doing create react app and then react
router so the first thing we want to do
is bring across that header so i'm going
to go and copy all of the header and
then go over into our source folder here
create a new directory called components
and a new file called header.tsx
and then paste that in
and the first thing i'm going to do is
we're going to get this from solid.js
and
we need a type called component
and we can replace this react function
component with just components the only
types of components we have in solid are
function components again we're looking
at
this as a replacement for the react that
we have today completely is that we
started from scratch so let's just try
and fix up all of the red squigglies as
we go the first one is this use memo so
in solid.js the version of that is
create memo basically does exactly the
same thing so we're going to do a create
memo there
it's not quite right yet but one of the
cool things is it doesn't require a
dependency array and i'll get to that in
a second why that's the case
but now continuing on
another big change is class name so
we're just going to change all of the
class name
to class
pretty easy right
now we've got this link here and we
don't actually have react right or dom
so let's bring in that
solid
app router that does have a link which
is great but in this case the 2 is just
href like that
now we've got these issues with product
okay so we do need to get the product
definition let's go over here to
products.ts i'll just copy and paste
that
into the source folder
call it
product ts
paste that in there so that gives us our
interface for what we get back from the
api
pretty easy
okay so continuing on
this is an interesting one on change is
a synthetic event in
react and it doesn't exist in solid what
you do get are the raw events because
it's a much smaller framework and
so in this case that would be on key up
and you don't get a target you get a
current target
all right pretty cool
now this is an interesting one so when
it comes to solid you don't use the map
system to go and iterate through
something you use a new
declaration called four
so i'm going to drop this in here
and then you give it whatever you're
going to iterate over so in this case
it's each and we will be iterating over
the cart
it's not quite right yet but let's go
and keep on going to this so
i'll drop this in here
so the content of the four is a function
that when
called we'll get each item in the cart
in this example
and then return out the
elements that are required to render
that so let's do
the key it actually is going to handle
that for us in this case
and this is actually starting to look
pretty good and then the last one in
here is that total and okay so
here's where we need to start thinking
about this as solid so the way that
solid does data management and binding
is pretty different and let's go over to
app and get that started so we can see
how that's all going to fit together so
over here in app
we've got our component we're going to
be bringing in that header so let's do
that
just like so
and we are going to be instantiating
that right at the top here
now there's a bunch of properties that
it doesn't have so we're going need to
go and create new state for that
so
we need a cart and we need a search
string so let's start with the search
string since it's a little easier so in
solid js the use date is called create
signal
so we'll start off with search
and we'll just start off with
an
empty string like that
and we can pass that on to
header
as well as on set search
which will get a string
and then do
a set search on that string
okay now notice that this is getting a
red curly and why is that well if i do
command k command i on this we can see
that this is an accessor if i go to the
type definition
it's an accessor is a function that
returns that type so in this case search
isn't the atomic type
of a string it's a function that returns
a string and when you call that function
you're essentially subscribing to it and
that's how solid.js does reactive state
management when you invoke one of these
signals you get a subscription to it and
then when the
value changes you automatically get
updated so let's go take a look over at
our header and see how we need to change
this this is going to turn into a
function that returns a string
and cart is going to turn into a
function that returns an array of
products so let's go take a look now at
this create memo
and what we really have is
cart
like reduce like that
so that actually becomes a lot cleaner
and here's the really cool part so when
cart changes total
changes dynamically automatically and
that's very important to understand
because this function header is only
going to get ever executed once okay so
let's go down and see how we're going to
use total
so in this case total isn't a value it's
a function so just like a signal with a
cart total is a function and by invoking
it you subscribe to it pretty cool stuff
okay so let's go down and continue
search in this case again it's going to
be an invocation like that cart
wanted me in a location like that and
we're looking pretty good of course
we're not passing in cart or clear cart
yet so let's go do that
i'm just going to go and
copy and paste that
create cart
set cart
start with an empty array
and you need to find that as a product
so we need to import product
and we'll define that that is an array
of products just like we would with use
date okay let's go and add cart
and then on clear cart
thank you github
nicely done okay so in this case we're
just going to set cart to an empty array
and let's see how we go
all right it's blowing up let's see why
it's blowing up if i go over here in the
console
we can see that our app is not wrapped
in a router so let's go fix that go back
into app
let's go over it into index.tsx
and then we'll bring in
router
from the solid.js app router
and just wrap the app in it
hey look at that looking pretty good
looking good great
and let's see if that actually works so
we'll go over here to app.tsx and we'll
just put that search string in here in a
div
and again it's not an atomic value it's
a function so we need to then call that
like that
looking pretty good you can kind of see
it in the corner there
looks awesome so the next thing you need
to do is bring in that home page
so let's go back over here bring in home
page
and i'll go and create a new component
homepage.tsx
again we're going to bring in component
from solid.js
and we're going to bring in the link
from that solid app router cool just
like that
okay this react function component
becomes a component
and
use memo we don't have that anymore we
have create memo
now where
use memo in react was essentially
optional
in
solid.js it is absolutely not optional
each component really only ever gets
executed once and we'll see that in a
little bit but basically if you've got
some code in here don't anticipate that
that's going to get run over and over
and over again like we would in react if
you want to have a derived value you
have to use something like create memo
so let's get rid of that dependency
array we don't use those because when
you invoke that function like in this
case the function that's going to return
products
then you're automatically subscribed to
that so this create memo knows that by
invoking this product
function
we are subscribing to products and
whenever products changes then this memo
needs to change this filter memo needs
to change all right you also get the
search string so let's put that in there
and we can see that
search
it also needs to become a function of
location just like that
now let's go through and change out all
our class names
and we'll change out the
two to an href on link
and there's no key anymore okay so this
is obviously in a map which it is so
let's go and do a four here
and we'll do each
and give it
filtered products which again is a
function
so we need to invoke that
now we can pretty much take this section
in here and just
copy it in there so let's go
get rid of that
paste that in
let's take a look so that actually
worked yeah that's got a product
seems to be pretty good
okay
so let's go back over to end to app and
start integrating this so the first
thing we need to do is bring in the
router so i'm going to go and copy and
paste in this
and bring in
routes and route
and we'll start off a section in here
with routes
and then within that oh that's pretty
good
all right and
we don't want header we want
home page just like that and in this
case with actually element
and we'll do home page
and what do we need on that we need on
add to cart we need products and search
so we have search that's pretty easy
and we have on add to cart that should
be pretty easy put that on the next line
and then set the card to the existing
cart
with the new product on there okay great
okay but now we need the list of
products and so we're going to use
something different for that we're going
to use a resource so i'm going to bring
in create resource
and create resources effectively what
you get if use state and use effect had
a baby api okay so let's use this and
we're gonna go and create
products
as a create resource yeah with a product
as an array that's gonna be the type of
it asks me a function
and let's go get the content of that so
that's a fetch to that fake store api
and we'll just drop that in there
very cool
okay so what this is basically saying is
create resources looking for a promise
that is fulfilled by fetch we are then
going to do that fetch and then we're
going to take the result of that and
pick out the json from that and that's
going to be what's going to go into
products so let's go and put that into
our app
like so oh looking pretty good okay
let's give it a try
let me hit refresh and i get a blow up
let's see what's happening
okay so let's go over to console
and we can see that we're trying to run
a filter on undefined so what's
happening here well in this case
create resource is starting as undefined
and then once this fetch is completed
then we've got an array so what i need
to do is give it an initial value which
is just a simple empty array
so i do that by adding on an optional
object give it initial value as an array
and away we go
hit refresh again and ah looking really
really good okay let's give it a try
let's add to cart
hmm interesting okay so it zips on over
there
that's okay
let's uh see why that is well if we go
over to home page
and scroll down
we have an event stop propagation in
there if we do event prevent default
does that help
let's save
all right looking pretty good
all right cool so the cart is updating
but we're not actually getting any value
changes so let's go and see why that's
the case
so we'll go back over to header
and we can see that i'm
invoking cart a little wrong here i'm
expecting again that kind of primitive
type and what i want is that array so
i'm gonna do cart like that that's cool
and the same sort of thing over here and
then the same thing down here
current length just like that
all right let's add a cart ah perfect
awesome so that reactivity is good to go
awesome so before we go on let's go take
a look back at app.tsx and see if we can
do this a little bit better so
we're doing a lot of prop drilling here
we're prop drilling into header we're
prop drilling into home page and if we
continued on like this we'd probably be
prop drilling into the product detail
page as well and sending up products can
we do better well we're used to going
and defining state inside the component
but you notice that create signal here
isn't called the use signal it's called
create signal which is different and as
it turns out that's a genuinely
functional difference because you can
invoke create signal from anywhere it's
really cool so i'm going to go and take
this and copy it and then create a new
file called
store.ts right at the top level here and
you can obviously put this anywhere you
want it
but i'm gonna go bring in
all of that just like that
and then i can just start exporting out
of here
all this stuff
and then i need to bring in
product just like that
yeah it looks pretty good okay
so what i can do now is i can go over to
my app
and i can actually get rid of this
and i can get rid of a lot of this
and a lot of this
all right and i know this is all
erroring out right now but we'll fix
that so let's go over to our header
first and fix that
so i'm going to be getting a lot of this
from that store so let's go and import
cart
and search
from the store
so let's go and clear out this
and then clear out all the properties
just like so
and we don't need product anymore that's
nice
okay but we are missing on add to cart
and also on set search so let's go and
create those in our store
okay that works and then
on clear cart
is just set the car to nothing
and on set search
yep that looks pretty good
let's export that to the const
nice okay great so let's go back in over
here and do on clear cart and on set
search
from the store okay
that looks pretty good not complaining
and let's jump over here to the homepage
do something similar so we're just going
to get rid of all this
and get rid of all the props
from store we will go get the products
and on add to cart i think
and probably also search right
awesome
and it's that easy to transition from
local component state to
global state so if you've got state that
you think it needs to be global you just
go and create that you can manage
context in this that works just fine too
but if you just need to have global
state you don't need to go and create
context just to pass that around it's
all just built right in and it's all
reactive which is just so cool
okay so now that we've done that let's
go over and bring in that product detail
page
create a new one called product detail
paste that in
again that will make that solid js
and we get muse params from the solid
app router great okay that's actually
right
and we're gonna get products from the
store
and on add to cart from the store
so let's change this react function
component to a component
get rid of our
inputs like that very cool
now we have a used memo here so let's go
and do create memo again
and this one is just finding the product
so do create memo and then we'll do
products
again as a function invocation
and once again we do not need the
dependency array because we don't need
to manually track that just by calling
products will automatically be
subscribed to products so if it changes
then we change automatically love it
all right so if we have a product
and let's just change all these
like so very cool
and we also got to change all our class
names
all right
that looks really good
and on add to cart is the current
product
great
awesome
okay let's try this out so let's go back
over here to our app
and we'll add in a new route
and from there we need our product
detail page
and look we no longer need product
detail or any of these boy the code is
cleaning up fast i love it
okay
part detail
and now if i click on this oh my god
that is so cool all right here we go add
to cart brilliant and if i just click
around inside of this i still get the
state which is great
but if i refresh then it's all gone so
let's see how we can hold that cart in
local storage like we did over in react
so i'm gonna go close out a bunch of
these windows
and then go back into store and i'm
going to use a different state
management mechanism again built right
into solid.js and that's called create
mutable
so create mutable allows you to create a
more complex shared structure that works
a lot like kind of a valshio or a mobx
so i'm going to go and create one called
cart
and then do create mutable and you give
it an object so in this case it's just a
list of products
and we'll start off with that as a
product
and we'll say oh okay so we need a total
and we'll make that a getter
and that's just going to return the
that's actually really good this
products reduce total product
yeah that's actually perfect okay thank
you again github co-pilot
so that's going to give us the total in
price of all the products so let's go
and add on add to cart
it'll take a product
and then this.products.push product
love it okay great and then clear cart
and that's just going to set that
product rated empty which is great
okay and then we can get rid of the cart
okay let's go see how we're going to go
and fix that over in the header
so we don't have on clear cart anymore
but we do have cart and we don't need
this memo so let's get rid of that get
rid of that create memo up there cool
and now we got cart.products.org
and then we replace this with
card.products
all right from here we can just make a
function
that does cart.clearcart
and then in here oh look at that we have
already our cart total that's awesome
cool
are there any other issues we have in
here up we got again a cart length so
let's do that cart.products.length
any other issues looking good great okay
moving on home page so add to cart isn't
there anymore so we'll place that with
cart
and then jump down here and do
cart dot add cart
easy peasy and let's go see same thing i
think probably same sort of thing here
yep so replace that with cart
awesome all right let's add a few things
the cart
looking good but if we refresh we still
have the same problem we're not doing
anything with local storage yet so let's
go fix that
and we'll go back over to the store okay
so the first thing we need to do is get
the local storage for cart
and if we don't find that then we need
to return an empty array as a string
because we're going to pass that into
json.parse
because local storage is a string it's
not an
object
and then to set it we're going to do
window.localstorage.set item
and then give it the cart
and that actually looks really good
thank you again github co-pilot
and let's save that out and see how we
go so let's refresh
very very cool okay so let's uh jump
over here add to cart add the cart
looking really good refresh it again
and
done
so we've seen a lot about how solid js
does reactive state management but
what's this other thing about the vdom
so
let's go and do something really cool
let's go in
in app let's do a console log
and we'll do app and then
index
plus plus
and i'll make index up here
and we'll just do the same sort of thing
for the header as an example
call that header
okay so let's go and bring up our
console and see how that worked
so we can see
that app got run once and header got run
once now if i go and add to cart
now everything's changing but we're not
getting any
reruns of those functions and that's a
really critical difference
what's happening here is this function
gets it run exactly once when it's
instantiated and then from there
this
it returns effectively a template a
dynamic template and when parts of that
template change
from this case for example the car
products then we automatically go and
update the
template but we don't rerun that
function and that's why you get the
dramatic efficiency boost when it comes
to solid js versus react so let's go
take a look at the react code and do the
same thing and see what happens in that
case
so over here in our tsx we'll go and
create an index
and i go on console.log it
and we'll do the same thing over in the
header
and we'll console lug it out of there as
well
now let's take a look at our react app
and bring up the inspector and the
console
and
every time we're adding something to
this we're getting complete re-render of
basically the entire stack from the app
on down
and what's happening is that those
functions are creating
a set of nested react elements and
that's being
assessed against the vdom and then the
updates are being made and the result is
in comparison to solid.js a lot slower
in fact how much slower well let's go
over it to the solid js documentation
and click on the performance
item and then there you've got vanilla
js at the bottom end obviously that's
gonna be the fastest thing if you hand
rope vanilla js there's a few
interesting things in between mikado
which is an entirely different system
there's wasm and then there's solid
and so solid is just slightly worse than
coding yourself in valuable js
and that's the really cool part here as
a react programmer
see how little difference there is
basically in how you code between solid
js and react but for that you get this
tremendous tremendous performance boost
and also
a great
reactive data management system built
right into it
okay so one more thing on the
performance side let me
bring up the terminal here and i'm going
to do a build
on the react side and then do the same
thing over in solid js land
and we can see how big the bundle sizes
compare
so okay it's over it's done here let's
open the build directory on this guy
so this is the react version
and we can see that the react is about
163k for the framework itself
and 4k
10k 12k on top of that so
175k
for the entire bundle for this little
ecommerce app now let's go take a look
over at our solid app and see how that
compares
let's create this directory
and we'll jump into that
and in there let's see js
oh yeah 6k
and then 22k for the vendor library so
28k
gets you solid.js and an entire
ecommerce application so really really
cool stuff okay so i promised the
beginning this video explaining why i
think that react is actually doing
something that it was never really
intended to in the first place and
that's a bit of a history lesson so we
kind of started all this with jquery
back in the day
and that was a great starting point but
when the complexity of apps got too
large we decided we needed a model view
controller type paradigm to go with and
so to do that we created systems like
backbone and thorax to manage the view
state as held separate from the state
because the state manager was going to
be complex and so was the view system
and we didn't want to get our peanut
butter and our chocolate together like
that so everybody thought that was cool
except for the fact that the view system
was based on templates and wasn't
encouraging component style reuse within
the system
so
at that point we got two different
alternatives you got angular which
basically said hey throw out everything
but you get
great state management and you also get
a cool component system
and also react which said hey keep your
state management system but will manage
all of the view state for you and the
only reason why react had any state
management system at all was because
each component could be a smart
component say for example a hierarchical
tree and you want to be able to manage
what the open and closed items were in
that hierarchical tree and that was the
only reason why you'd have any state in
it at all was to manage that kind of
view state and all the actual
applications date was gonna be managed
by what you'd previously done with
backbone
and then we said well you know that
really doesn't work all that well
with react so
facebook came up with the flux paradigm
which was popularized by redux and that
became sort of the standard go-to from
then going forward but you always had
these two systems you always had to pair
react with essentially a state
management system because react was
never meant to be the state manager and
then we got hooks and hooks were close
enough to being a state management
system where we kind of looked over the
fundamental flaws but again getting back
my original point
it's always important as an engineer to
say knowing what we know today can we be
doing better and the fact of the matter
is react was never meant to be a fully
fleshed out state management system and
so that's what solid is trying to
address it's trying to both give you a
performance benefit in terms of losing
the v dom but also give you a
real world production ready state
management system
built right into the framework and
addressing what the original commenter
said which was a fundamental flaw
in their react system so a little bit of
a history lesson there but i hope you
understand and conceptualize now
why
solid js not only exists but honestly
needs to exist if the react ecosystem is
to evolve at this point i'm sure you
have some questions for me about this
really cool new framework if you do
please put those in the comments section
down below youtube loves your comments
and i love answering your comments as
well
and of course feel free to like this
video if you liked it and hit that
subscribe button if you want to see more
videos just like it